[Musique]
ce festival est important pour nous
parce qu'il va chercher les jeunes dans
les quartiers chercher les jeunes c'est
ramener aussi les parents avec eux donc
c'est leur proposer différents
spectacles et leur proposer de l'art et
de la culture dans les quartiers pas
très loin de chez eux donc pour pouvoir
les faire voyager tout en restant à
Saint-André
c'est déjà ça apprend à se découvrir
parce que c'est aussi à la base une
culture de rue donc on se construit dans
la rue on apprend aussi le respect dans
la rue et c'est peut-être l'endroit qui
a le plus besoin mais c'est là qu'il
existe peut-être le plus et c'est ce
qu'on transmet aussi dans les écoles le
savoir vivre ensemble la valorisation la
fierté d'être etc et que ça c'est la rue
qui nous l'a enseigné
[Musique]
il fait plaisir et il peut encore plus
se faire moins encore plus plaisir que
la le service culturelles appelle-moi on
peut être le parrain donc vraiment c'est
infinité mécontent d'autant plus que ce
dimanche ne finit pas un gros concert de
moi-même avec DJ Phil voilà franchement
il m'y invite toute bonne danseuse de
l'île de la Réunion à venir parce que
c'est un gros festival et ça va être
bien ça va être bien il faut venir il
faut venir il faut venir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]